this is a production of Cornell
University uh so I'm going to present
the work that we are doing in the lab in
the past year and a half and it's
basically related with the hydrology
that we have been observing in the indog
ganger Plains and the correlation with
the greenhouse gas
emissions so I'm going to do a quick H
background so as Andy mentioned before
uh the ipcc the last latest report um
from ipcc report that agriculture
contribute with 22% of the global
greenhouse gas emissions uh within the
sector Rice have a single category as a
single crop they hold a whole category
and that contribute with 8% this a small
small number here 8% of the greenhous
gas emissions from agriculture uh mainly
for methan emissions from par
Fields so where all this methane come
from um from Asia because it's is the
region that produce about 90% of the
rice that they also consume and the the
region is a Hotpot of methan
emissions uh but rice is not just a mean
methane hosit it's also a very important
crop for food security and economic crop
so I don't want to like uh blame rice
because actually it's more benefits than
than than consequences that we have it's
just that we need to learn how to face
the challenges around the
intensification of the crops so it's
also important because a rice is the
main calor intake Source H for a tier of
the population in in the world that is
located in Asia and I know that South
America is knowing the map like a Hotpot
but we ate a lot of rice there as well
it's just that Asians want this but yeah
it's very important for many things and
is the reason that the focus on the rice
specific as a crop a take more relevance
in the future also because the missions
that are produced will be a problem in
the future for growing rice in the in
the region as well so it's like a double
f a a problem so why
Rice have this relevance in the
mitigation goals and why ipcc take a
Chapter to say about rice rice crop is a
very like particular crop and it's
different for a other crops because they
can survive in anoxic uh conditions so
most of the Agricultural soils have
these kind kind of like um processes
biochemical processes in the soil where
the oxygen can like go through the roots
and the microbes can do the anerobic
respiration but in rice fields that are
PR to be flooded for like a extended
periods uh the rice have a physiological
adaptation that allow the exchange of
the gas so then all the meane that is
produced here that is a different
process from the mission
can be released to the atmosphere
through the plant so here is a picture
that I sto from
internet and you can see some of the
spaces that is called the AR enima and
is from the gases can exchange so it's
how the oxygen come to the roots but as
the meane is reles to the atmosphere and
this picture is just a reference how the
rice field looks like so just imagine
that 805 or more per of the meane that
is produced here in the field is is
going up through the plant uh and about
50% by a when you see this Bine in the
in pting water or the diffusion is very
slow but it still
happens so these mechanisms that I just
described operates in different scales
and also are influenced by different
drivers and it's just getting more
complex and complex when you are
expanding this scale so these uh soil
water plant relationship H going to
perform differently depend of the
genotypes or the architecture of the of
the of the Arena that differs among
genotypes that are more adapted to
anerobic conditions than others but then
the soil going to add a new like
interaction with the carbon and nitrogen
pools so when you zoom out a little bit
the scale you're going to find that the
soil is not the same everywhere and then
for that reason farmers have to take
decision on how manage the soils so then
we have not just the plan interacting
with the very local soil parameters but
also with the variability of those
parameters and the farmer's decisions so
all this start to drive more complexity
in the missions and in a very very large
scale that is the focus of our work
right now is the landscape variability
and mostly how the water is Distributing
the ecosystems in a in a natural form
and this depends of elevation the
geomorphology and the aquer
characteristics so when the farmers can
receive water from rainfall or they take
for Reser BS or or for the canels or how
they distribute the water in the
ecosystem in a large scale so all the
work that you're going to find about
greenhouse gas emissions in rice is
located located in this area or this
like special scale and we start to see
more papers that try to link these
agronomic beh behaviors or these
agronomic decisions in a landscape and
try to see how the landscape can
actually be a highl source uncertainty
on the current greenhouse gas
estimations that are very high I'm not
blaming ipcc but I know that they are
doing their best but there are a lot of
work that we need to address so even if
the problem is already here we are still
figure out how to quantify
emissions so there are a very special
place in the world
that in which all these interactions
that I mentioned before become even more
complex because of the nature of the
landscape and is the indog ganger plains
that were were
prod they are created for the collision
between two plages the Indian and the
and the Chinese and they deform the
Himalayas and thanks to those geological
processes and Isa really active a
flal
region this area is very productive in
India and is is where the most of the
rice is producing in the region so for
the most popular country in the world
this region produce more than a half of
the cereal that they eat and remember
that rice is a very important staple
crop in the region so it's no a minor
crop or a minor region to do this so at
the same time it's a it's a Hotpot and
is an important area for mitigation as
well so there are many things happening
here I just I get too excited when I
talk about the geomorphology of here so
we can discuss this later because I know
that I gonna get a stuck talking too
much about this
so we have a working hypothesis and is
that the hydrology is the major driver
of the greenhouse gas emissions in those
conditions there are some areas that you
can think that a landscape is pretty
much homogeneous that we can see a
hectar and hectars of the same land in a
monocrop but this is not happening in
the indogan plains and also because
there are a big portion of a small
farmers that operate and taking
different decisions based on what they
are located and so we think that this is
are all sources of a uncertainty and the
estimations
so and we also think that there are no
represent ative site that we can see
okay this side can represent in the
hydrology or the emissions in this
region there are many sites and they
just can change seasonally so it's very
challenging to determine this but uh we
set three
objectives to try to describe this the
first one is try to describe the
hydrological responses that we observe
in the indog ples OR at least in a small
part uh then try to identify if there
are a relationship between these
patterns and greenhous gas emissions and
the last one was try to I think that
that's is writing in Spanglish but I'm
going to explain what what we want to do
is see how the hydrological information
can actually inform about mitigation
hotspots or areas that can be important
for mitigation
actions I don't it like not too bad
there so I'm going to explain the
materials and methods so I have this
workflow so the work is dividing two the
in two parts so the first H source of
data that I used to analyze or to solve
these H objectives was simulating the
greenhouse gas emissions in some sites
in in the Indo G planes and at the same
time we did a cluster analysis of the
hydrological responses that we observe
so when I was very frustrated doing the
NDC I just jump in the in the cluster
analysis and I spent the last year just
working on both when I was studed one of
the and Professor David Ros also support
us in this task ER in the
characterization of the hydrological
behaviors and there are another ongoing
work analyzing more methodological
aspects of clustering and classification
and mapping the hydrological behavior so
I'm just going to show the very final
results but there are more work that we
are doing in this
part um then based on the simulations
and the closer analysis or the yeah the
cluster that resulted we analyze the
correlations with the missions we
analyze the the what is the implications
of agronomic management on different
hydrology hydrological patterns that we
identify that we identify so I'm going
spoil the the seminar a little bit but
and the last one was just try to see if
we can use this data to classify areas
that can be prone to have high h mean
emissions so this is the study area so
you can see that is very at the North
very close to Nepal um the pink H dots
are the the sampling sites in 2021
during Carib season they were about 47
sites and the green dots are the
160 sites located across ER bear the
distribution of the sites are more
logistic than corresponding to any other
like experimental approach that we want
is a very challenging a extend area even
if it's just one part of the indogan
plane so the distribution of the points
were more like based on a the best way
to distribute the resources personnel
and and time trying to do some sampling
uh again I'm just going to don't talk
about the rivers because I get too
passionate again but there are like a
very rich hydrological Behavior there
and the rivers can be feed by the
Glasser water ground water rainfall
water and this can get areas floated for
different Prime periods during the year
so it's very hard to Define what is a
characteristic side here
because it also depends of the time of
the year and how heavy was the monsoon
or not so it's very
challenging so sorry so we collect they
collect because they collect this before
I arrive to cor actually but in 2021 and
2022 the syrial assistant Initiative for
South Asia office uh at simit they
collect a field water monitoring data so
they install a a PVC pipes
in in the in the fields that in the
sites that I showed before and they
monitor monitoring the water level like
here every day during this period that
July between July and November in 2021
and
2022 at the same time they take some
soil samples to analyze some basic soil
analysis and also collect the agronomic
data associated with those sites so what
Farmers how fertil how much fertiliz
they use
uh if they irrigate or not and they
sewing and harvesting date if somebody's
interested on this data is available in
the repository of uh simit if you have
any assignment and you need data or
something like that is there and
additional I need for the modeling of
green Co Gas emissions climate data so I
just took from the power NASA a web page
and I just link with the closest a areas
er um in the map so I create six files
for
2021 and 23 files for 2022 try to match
some differences that we spot in the
gauges and just try to have more
accurate data I use the model dndc I
don't know if you are familiar with this
model it's a process based model that
simulate carbon and Nitro nitrogen
cycling in the soil in agroecological
system
so the inputs that I use for run these
simulations uh were like the location
inputs the climate that I mentioned
before uh the initial soil conditions
that some of them were taken directly
from from the field but but some of them
that have this atics are were um values
that I calculate with pedot transfer
functions if you want more detail about
this we can just discuss like I can just
uh
show you later the the PED transfer
functions that I use uh the ammonia was
estimate was estimated by the mo and the
agronomic management was the same so we
assume the same agronomic Management in
all sites because what we want to see is
the effort of the hydrology in every
site and so the only the only change in
the agronomic management among the sites
was the water table file so we created a
one year water type of fight that Define
what was the water level every day
during the whole year so this is the
only differences that you going to spot
in the missions across the SES is the
water um we did a calibration of the
crop parameters uh fortunately
unfortunately I don't know the NDC is
not a model that you can do too many
calibration or tuning but of crop so
it's easy calibrate because it's few
parameters that you can do but at the
same time it's not that robust if you
want to improve your simulations so we
did some simulations when I subset a a
group of farms from
2021 and I use some
references uh from the data that I need
to do the calibration that I start with
calibrating the biomass and then the
thermal degree days and finally the
water requirement following the protocol
suggested by part
partridge in
11 so this is the part of the simulation
so I just simulate greenhouse gas
emissions in every site that I showed
before in 2021 and in 2022 at the same
time H we are doing a hydrological
description of the sites using the time
series of the field water level
so this analysis was first I calculate
some hologic Des scriptures that are
based on what I think that can influence
the missions or the scriptures that can
actually help me to explain the
variability in the missions they are no
definitive and they are not like fixed
and there are not like standardized
indicators for that was just the way
that we try to describe this time series
so at the end of the monitoring we
receive a like spreadsheet like this so
every rout was a daily record of of the
mission sorry the field water level and
every rout is the farms and the columns
sorry are the daily data so for each of
them I estimate or I calculate sorry
these hydrological descriptores that are
based on the flood period so basically
the duration of the floods how high was
the water table and the total period
flooded and another category that was
the drainage period so for how long was
drainage uh how deep was the was drained
and then a transition between saturate
and saturate conditions that was how
many floods you can observe or how
flushy was the field so with this we we
aim to describe the hydrological
behavior and also try to associate with
emissions and then we have some data
that looks like this like just try to
see that there are some sides that are
more dry than others the water column
are like higher than others and the
duration of the floods were actually
longer in 2021 than
2022 and then we try to all this
data H use a keyin algorithm to Cluster
in in groups and try to find if there
are as some hydrological groups that
share some of these descriptores
Behavior so until that I I kind of er me
the first objective that was try to
describe the the hydrological behavior
and the two other objectives was very
simple analysis of analysis of a
variance and trying to correlate the
Clusters with the missions associated
with the Clusters and try to see if
there are some differences between them
and also we did a sensitivity analysis
based on the centroids of those clusters
so try to check them more representative
side of H cluster and run a sensitivity
analysis changing the nitrogen and
carbon inputs and see what happened when
you have a different hydrological
Behavior what is happening with the
nitrogen and the carbon so it's not the
same so stop to assume that if you put
more carbon everything will be fine and
if you reduce the nitrogen everything
will be fine is is more complex than
that I already said the results but
anyway the the the teer point is as
basically uh the we did a classification
tree and we create some categories for
for the mean emissions and then we try
to see with a random forest model how
the prediction potential of this data
and then just try to see how it looks
like in a classification Tre and see how
informative you know how this can looks
and the potential
use we are not too ambitious with that
what the first try we are trying to
improve this part so now I'm going to
present the results I'm going to start
with the simulations and then start to
just combine with the
Clusters so the first part is the the
simulation from all the sides so you can
see that in 2021 in West champan that is
one District within bear the missions
were the double the main emissions were
the double that observed in bear in the
rest of the State uh from the next year
and the Nitros oxide emissions were
actually like basically the same in
2021 but in 2022 you can see like that
wasn't just so much higher compared with
2021 but also have like a bigger
dispersion and er when you see the
cluster you're going to see
why uh the special distribution of the
emissions in the map just show that you
can have high High greenhouse gas
emissions everywhere and low greenhouse
gas emissions everywhere and even if you
can associate a small areas with low or
high emissions there are no special
pattern or gradient that you can
associate make it more complex so that
mean that people I mean I know that is
the only way that we can find out but
it's very loose when you say West
champan District have these emissions
per hectar or beard is emitting this
amount when we have this variability in
the
area so the cluster for
2021 present five H
groups uh the cluster explain 86% of the
variance so we we reorganize the number
of the cluster to to match dest clusters
with the numbers so one is the driest
why is the wetest okay and so you can
see that there are a clear distinction
between the Clusters and this
distribution that you can see here is
based on the seasonal Monsoon rainfall
so there are no irrigation invol here
and this is just what happening during
the season that was unusal a heavy like
Monson a season the distribution of the
sides or the cluster members in in the
map is also very
random the the distribution of the
samples is not necessarily the best to
describe the special behavior of a
parameter because it's very random and
there are many points localized in some
areas so we actually didn't know what's
happening for instance between this
point and this point but at least we can
give a sense that everything can happen
everywhere in the indog ganger Plains
and this make very uncertainty the the
extrapolation of greenhous gas emissions
so just assume that because I find this
representative side so all the neighbors
going to have more or less the same
Maybe not maybe no no no so H this is
the distribution so as I just going to
recall this distribution of the water in
the
field was completely natural and it's
based on the location of the sites and
the water that come from rainfall and
the floods from the
rivers but in 2022 we have something
more
random uh the analysis also find that
five clusters will be the best way to to
disaggregate the groups but in this case
the model just can explain 67% of the
variability and you can see that is very
like random I've been seeing this map
for like more than one year so I'm
already tired and I can see patterns I
can see more things that you see right
now but for all of you might be
something just like there are no any
pattern there are no any correlation is
very hard to see but you can see that
the number one cluster is the driest and
five is the is the wetest but in the
cluster three you can see that actually
there are many sites that behave like
the two or four and in this case is very
contrasting to the 2021 because in 2022
was a very extreme year dry year so this
distribution of the water that you can
see here is induced by irrigation so
farmers in those sites irrigate between
two and 30 times I can tell there are
some places that they just irrigate 30
times I need to show you the you look
surpris and there are some SES but but
what what depends how many times a
farmer can irrigate depends of how much
water they need how much resources they
have uh how much they want to put in the
field when they can so it's very random
those decisions are very random and
remember that those Farms are very SC
small scale Farms so the patterns can be
very hard to catch with the in the
scriptures that we use this time uh for
instance was like just after the
analysis that one of the cesa
researchers explain us that these uh
sites that you can see that are very
flushy like they have more than 10 cm of
water in the field and then next day was
completely drainage and again and this
is very neutral you cannot see a natural
like phenomenon that can do this uh the
natural phenomenon is the humans just
putting so much water because they were
close to the canal so they can afford
this kind of a floods but it's
completely artificial so in this case
how we can correlate one season to
another even if are not the same place
when the nature of the the distribution
of the water was completely different
and this is the kind of complexity that
we see in this H regions even if we are
not saying that are the same place but
it's the kind of random L that you can
find uh so here I'm compare the
greenhouse gas emissions I'm sorry I
just going to back
quick you can see this is too light but
here is the main
emissions and the green bars are the
nitrous
oxide so you can see that in the dry
sides you have less methane emissions
and in the wetest SES you have more
greenhouse gas emissions and Nitros oide
is a littleit bit like random but I'm
going to explain why I just going to
back quick sorry uh in 2021 is like the
driest have like some sides that are
very like low emissions but in overall
the wet sides have more emissions and
Nitros oxide was basically the
same okay now I can back here
oh so when I compare the the greenhouse
gas emissions per per cluster we find
that there are a correlation or there
are yeah there are a correspondence
between the driest clusters with low
greenhouse gas emissions mean emissions
and the wetest Clusters or sides with
high methane
emissions uh but you can see here that
nitrous oxide doesn't have the same
correlation we only can find a trade-off
in
2022 where while the meane increase when
the
wetest conditions increase the Nitros
oxide kind of a reduce that is the
typical tradeoff that you read in the
papers about Nitros oxide and methane
when it's floated Nitros oxide is not
like possible in the field but when it's
dry then you have nitrous oxide and the
methane is is
low uh but this is also a complex and it
have this definition is very simplistic
because it's more complex than that the
yellow H bars that you can see here are
marking the time during the
fertilizations took place every season
and if you see here I just show put this
more transparent sorry but basically the
field conditions flood condition or
saturate conditions in almost all those
sides at least in the in the last three
sides were basically the same so when
the fertilizations come place was
completely flooded even if after that
period the sides present like
differences that drive differences in
the
mean but in 2022 you can see that there
were like more more like major
differences across the Clusters and
actually if you see the cluster four
that is this you see that the
variability is very high or the
dispersion of the data is very high and
it's because some of the sides you can
see here are completely dry during the
fertilization period even if in overall
those sides were continuous floated
after that and are associated with high
a methane emissions so is the reason
that is very simplistic assume that high
Nitros oxide emissions are necessarily
linked with low methane emissions it's
not all Thea is not the cas in all the
time so the the missions were correlated
with some of the Des scriptures so we
can use some of the Des scriptures to to
to associate with the greenhous gas
emissions and the totas they floated was
positive correlated with the methane
that have completely
s and I saw the percentage of days that
the field was floated at more than 10
CMS also have a a positive correlation
and have a negative correlation with the
number of days that the water was
drained below 10 CMS basically all the
roots zone or the roots and the
microbial activities taking place was
completely dry and when you have more
days like this you going going to have
less meain emissions for sure so this is
the that the analysis show and also like
the duration of the
floods uh if it's more than one month or
a month of course that be associate with
more emissions I don't think it's pretty
obvious but is what we get and the
duration of the floods of one day have a
negative impact so it's basically saying
that if you have just very very short
floting conditions is not
necessarily like informative to be
positive in terms of a main emissions
because what create the mean or
methanogenesis conditions is like
continuous flooding or like prolonged
floods so actually the duration of
floods or short-term durations are
negative correlated with the with the
emissions so just to sum we find some
patterns that they are correlated with
human induced like patterns or nature
induced patterns and those patterns are
associated with high or low Nitros oxide
emissions but in a very short scale
within the cropping season are
associated with high or low Nitros oxide
so it's just getting more complex and
and complex so here uh we try to assess
the interaction with the Nitro nitrogen
and carbon ER pools so soils have a
natural like carbon pools and nitrogen
pools some soils are more fertile than
others but Farmers try to address this
issue adding more nitrogen and in India
there are an issue of overuse of
fertilizers and so we want to address
this issue
so the thing
is sometimes some practices have been
like over
promoted and saying that is good for
something but there are missing a key
part that depends on the context so not
all practice is going to deliver the
same
mitigation a impact in all places and
this is the part that we are like
overlooking when this practices are
promoted and I talking specifically for
the crop residue
retention so there are a tradeoff h in
terms of the nitrogen H in the driest
side if you add more nitrogen you're
going to create a Hotpot of nitrous
oxide and when you add um or when you
left more organic matter in the field uh
you're going to have more meain
emissions ER in in in sides that are
more flooded so the management of the
missions or if you don't want to
increase methane emissions in in sites
that are mostly flooded you need to take
take care of the timing of when you
incorporate the the residues and on left
that the residues are DEC composed in
anerobic
conditions do this is is easy to say
than do it in the field because as I say
is a very complex like interaction with
the field when the farmers have like the
resources to do that the researchers
suggest so there are like a
disconnection between what we suggest
and Farmers actually can do but
basically this is the message just try
to avoid the residue is is is DEC compos
or break down in anerobic conditions and
in terms of a Nitros
oxide it's basically like the Nitros
oxide can become a Hotpot in areas that
we don't have a Hotpot of emissions if
we don't take care of the of the
nitrogen fertilization so we have a very
dry side that doesn't have any problem
of meane emissions but if farmers are
overusing the nitrogen they are actually
creating a hospot so we need to take
care of that uh just like the the Nitros
oxide in the rice fields is even a
little bit more complicated because
there are a moisture window in which the
Nitros oxide can occur by nutrification
and D nutrification so in very dry soils
like the moisture is below 30% 40%
nitrification D nitrification took place
very slow nitrification sorry very slow
and a very slow rate then between 60
70 85% of moisture in the soil both
processes take place so you're going to
have like this spike in the Nitros oxide
emissions and given the floating and
refling events in rice you can have it's
very likely that you can have these
conditions in the soil to promote D
nitrification in the soil as well that
is something something that doesn't
happen in well drained soils so it's
very risky and it's the reason that we
need to take care of of that not just
reducing the amount of nitrogen is also
taking care of the imbalance in the
field because not necessarily a low rate
of
nitrogen is is efficient because you can
affect the gelds and it's not
necessarily what we
need so the key message here was the
hydrology play a role in in in how the
management can be done and how much can
affect the the greenhouse gas emissions
and at the same time can become a
practice a really good practice as
incorporate organic matter uh as a like
potential issue when the mean emissions
are increasing because the Mal adoption
of the practices so again it's just send
the message that hydrology need to be a
important context when we talk about
mitigation strategies in
agriculture
um this is okay the the the decision of
the
cluster the way that the cluster uh was
separated in HG defer so we estimate the
feature of importance in a year for the
Clusters and we find that in West
champan the the the the scriptures that
Define longest
um longest uh duration of floods
actually are more important to separate
or disaggregate the Clusters and in 2022
the duration of the flots was also
important but it's more important like
short duration a des scriptures why
because some of the Des scriptures don't
happen too often in the order so we
don't have more than one mon of floods
in 2022 then use the Des scripture
to close in 2022 was completely useless
or if you have a continuous floting
conditions uh the scripture
like a number of days drainer is not too
useful and this also address the issue
that is very complicated
Define how to describe the hydrological
behavior because the behavior is not
necessarily the same every season and
the example that we see in 2022 is the
distribution of the water that you see
in the field is because the farmers were
adding water but we didn't check or we
didn't couldn't see the real like
natural potential of the areas to be
flooded because there w't enough water
to show us which areas can be floated
for a long time when you have heavy
rainfall that was wasn't possible
because was too drive that year so it's
likely that even next season we can see
a completely different distribution of
the water and some of these Des
scriptures have not be useful anyways
because they are not too informative
it's just getting more
complex and so this is the last part and
it's
basically uh what I was saying before
about how we can use this data to inform
mitigation actions and hotpots so first
I just combine the whole data and run a
random forest model so I just split the
test data and the the the train data
remember that I have
207 points so it's a very small data set
for these kind of tools but I want to
try
any it's free so I did and then we see
that the most important factors for the
random Forest analysis to have to
classify the emissions where they total
days flooded and the number of days the
water drops below 50 CMS is basically a
compensatory like the scriptures when
was floated and when was dry it's very
basic and I I like that was that basic
but I don't want to assume that it's
that simplistic it's just that the
analysis show us that but it's not that
it's not that that
simple so the the mod did maybe because
I did I say that was very good but it's
not that bad considering the small data
set and that actually is just based on
the of the hydrological descriptions and
knowing the in the in other parameters
like nitrogen and carbon so there are
like a missing part and I still can
explain some of the differences in in
mean the rules that you can see here are
very straightforward for Define very low
emissions areas and very high so when
you have more than 63% of drainage
conditions it's likely that the
emissions will be according to this
analysis A no more than 50 kilograms of
methane per season that is already high
and this is a white range from 0 to 56
so what makes this range change in in in
this H decis in this classification note
and is the distribution of this small
percent of the floods that was as I say
here like there are six we six weeks
where six weeks of continuous flooding
or six weeks of just like intermittent
flooding and it's going to change like
the the amount of emissions I think that
I have five minutes so if you want to
know more about the tree just we can go
in the in the question
questions I'm just going to jump into
the conclusions so the first one is that
the a concept of Representative sites is
not
necessarily like a good approach to
define a how to describe the indog
ganger planes and because the hydrology
is very complex and the seasonal changes
as well so yeah it's a bit bit tricky to
do this and as we don't have a represent
resentative side we don't have a
representative emissions associated with
those sites because can be anything
again and so this made that the
estimations like using tier one
approaches can be very loose but then
use um process based models or more
sophisticated tools can be very time
demanding because then you have to
calibrate for every place that you want
to do the analysis so again we need to
rethink the way that we are addressing
this issue of the
estimations and if we want to know or we
want to actually determine how much the
mitigation potential of agronomic
practices can can deliver to Farmers we
need to frame this in a hydrological
context especially in the indog ganger
Plains it's no way that always when you
implement
AWD you're going to have a reduction of
30% of meane I know this memory because
you can go to go online and you can read
is is fixed no it's like now that people
are associate practices with a certain
amount of main
reduction and is is uses as a daily
basis people just say that like yeah
it's that but it's not necessarily true
because now we know that is depending of
the context and the context is wi
diverse in those areas so it's very
uncertain associate a practice with a
mitigation po mitigation potential and
the last one is the approaches that ER
rooting the hydrology in the region can
be very useful for policy
makers because again the political
boundaries of India are not necessarily
the geomorphological boundaries of India
uh in the same way we need to address
the challenges no based on the the
political boundaries or or where the
university can do their work is more
like we need to think this more broadly
and take decisions based on that
um the last one is that all this work is
a initial work that we are doing so this
is a very preim preliminary work and we
are going to complement the results that
you can see here we are improved because
we know that there are many areas that
we can improve in those results uh we
have in 2000 this year they are
finishing the field water monitoring for
the same sites in 2022 so this season
we're going to have the opportunity to
compare same sides how much change the
the hydrological
Behavior Uh we're going to migrate to
orisa B3 now orisa is a very powerful
crop model for rice and now they have
the capability to simulate greenhouse
gas emissions the NDC is very poor doing
the crop part so now that we have
productivity and greenhous gas emissions
I think that we can actually get more
precise conclusions and more holistic
like a answers on on the
problem and we are also
so the the CES are collecting data on
irrigation surveys and see how much can
be useful to describe the hydrology
adding with the field water monitoring
and remote sensing and new products of
satellites that is coming in the in the
next months so we're going to try to
combine the tools and these data sources
to trying to find the best ways to
describe the temporal and spatial
variation of the hydrology now that we
know that there are some correlation
with with the missions and then we start
to re refine how to estimate the the
missions
there and we are also measuring
greenhous gas emissions this season uh
we are assessing some scenarios and yeah
we are trying to use these for
calibrate the the models and just try to
see what this a will looks not just for
Rice season also what are the
consequences of these floating
conditions after in winter season and
all the interactions but we are on that
so I think that they are yeah they
finished K season this this year and
yeah this is the work that we are doing
so as I say it's unfinished work and we
are still like working on improving the
methods and interpreting the results and
with new data we hope that we can just
do a better understanding or of the of
the hypothesis that we are like trying
to to
puzle and yeah this is all thank
you maybe you mentioned it and I I don't
know if I maybe I did not just
understood at the up front you were
talking about ipcc estimating the
emissions from from Rise
production and that it was based on a
representative site so based on what you
saw do you think that ipcc over
estimates or
underestimates the ipcc use
representative site the the ipcc use
representative Water Management so if
you go to the ipcc there are SC scaling
factors to Define like it was continuous
floating so you use a different scaling
factor in the area if it's intermittent
if it's multiple irations or single
Iration so in some cases depending of
the person that are doing the analysis
they going to assume that this area is
completely flooded when maybe not and
and in this case they're going to
overestimate the emissions and in some
areas that they are assuming that they
need to use a es scale factor for a
intermittent irrigation even it was
mostly prone to be flooded they going to
have a underestimation so the problem is
like er the distribution of the water is
is more complex than just four
categories I think that you can you can
check for the way that the this describe
the area that they are trying to
estimate how far they are from from the
analysis so but yeah it's hard to know
if they are I think that in some regions
they are just
overestimated in others are
underestimated and I depending of the
season because as I see in 2021 was
completely flooded and was the double of
the missions that we see in 2022 and
wasn't nothing that the farmers can do
to control that thanks again Laura
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu